una partícula se mueve en el plano xy
por lo que en cualquier tiempo t mayor o
igual a cero la posición del vector es
nos da en el componente x y el
componente y para la posición de nuestro
vector y los dos componentes están en
función del tiempo entonces cuál es el
vector de aceleración de la partícula
ente igual a tres bueno nuestra posición
que es una función vectorial está en
función del tiempo y es un vector y nos
han dicho que el componente x de nuestra
posición es menos 3 d al cubo más 4 t al
cuadrado y el componente i es igual a de
kubica + 2 entonces si nos dan un tiempo
mayor o igual a cero simplemente lo
sustituimos aquí y podremos obtener los
componentes xy ahora esta es una forma
de escribir la anotación de un vector
pero otra forma de escribirlo es con
bueno tal vez estén familiarizados con
la anotación de ingeniería
se escribe de esta manera menos 3 por t
al cubo más 4 porte cuadrada por el
vector unitario que se encuentra en
dirección horizontal más te cúbica más 2
por el vector unitario en dirección
vertical y esto simplemente nos ayuda a
representar lo mismo este es el
componente x y este es el componente que
este es el componente en dirección
horizontal y este es el componente en
dirección vertical es decir el
componente y ahora aquí la clave es que
si conocemos el vector de posición
entonces el vector velocidad será la
derivada de eso entonces de dt es igual
a r prima de t que será igual a bueno
simplemente necesitamos sacar las
derivadas correspondientes de cada
componente hagamos eso si queremos sacar
la derivada del componente x con
respecto al tiempo tenemos 3
por menos 3 eso es menos 9 de cuadrada
más 2 x 4 que es 8 entonces más 8 por t
y después para el componente y la
derivada de t al cubo con respecto a t
es 3d al cuadrado y la derivada de 2 es
0 entonces sólo tenemos 3 d al cuadrado
ok y si queremos encontrar el vector de
aceleración en el tiempo eso es igual a
la derivada de la velocidad con respecto
al tiempo entonces esto es igual a vamos
a dejar los espacios vamos a ver para el
componente x simplemente sacamos la
derivada de esto es decir del componente
x y nos queda que 2 x menos 9 es igual a
menos 18 por t
8 pues la derivada de 8 t con respecto a
t s 8 y después en el componente y la
derivada de 3 de cuadrada es igual a 2 x
3 que es igual a 6 por t o mejor dicho 6
t entonces al sacar la derivada de la
posición de este vector pudimos
encontrar el vector de aceleración y
ahora sólo necesitamos evaluar esto
cuando te es igual a 3
entonces el vector de aceleración ente
igual a 3 es igual a menos 18 por 3 más
8 coma después tenemos 6 por 3 6 por 3
ok y esto a que es igual bueno esto es
igual
vamos a ver menos 18 por 3 es menos 54 y
menos 54 más 8 es igual a menos 46 y
después 6 por 3 que es igual a 18
está bien esto es menos 54 8 entonces
menos 54 4 es menos 50 y más otros 4 nos
queda menos 46 sí ahí lo tiene menos
46,18 este es el vector de aceleración
entre igual a 3